all right
time for a movie retrospective i can't
believe
that we've been doing these [ __ ]
retrospectives this long and we have not
done this movie yet
i thought we did do this movie uh no we
did not we've done
uh some of the other classics like i
said we did you know friday the 13th
movies
we did all that kind of stuff we did
other toby hooper movies even we did
life force we did the fun house however
we have not done the granddaddy of all
slasher flicks i guess
the texas chainsaw massacre and actually
i wanted to do it this week because uh
this right here this blu-ray which is
very fantastic at leatherface and got
sally on there like that yeah that's a
that's a steel book edition it is it's
steel book it's
beautiful uh this was sent to me by
dominic friend of the show a very long
time ago
and um he had it was like in the pile of
movies and he asked about it the other
day and i was just like oh maybe we
should do that because we haven't even
done the [ __ ] texas chainsaw massacre
only one of the most classic horror
movies like ever made
so you know we finally decided to get
around to it looks like it got a little
bit crushed there i straightened it out
though it's all right
yeah this actually has uh you know the
movie's been restored since like the
40th anniversary edition this also has
four count them four commentary tracks
on there with all different people check
out this other [ __ ] i also got i think i
showed this once on the ed geen show or
maybe there was like a picture of it
look i have like a little tiny
leather face yeah toy they came in a set
there's also a jason
and a freddy uh also and they have
little environments and whatnot i just
thought that was super cute
but yeah so this was a movie this came
out in 1974 obviously
the thing that's very funny to me about
this movie
is that and i've seen it probably like a
million times i think i
maybe have it memorized but one of the
things and i think i've brought this up
on like a lot of other
of our other uh movie retrospectives
when we're talking about movies
and i love the way that everything in
this movie
like people remember this as like a
really nasty like gory you know blood
fest and everything like that and it's
not they show hardly anything nothing
happens in it a bunch of screaming
they show [ __ ] gross [ __ ] that's it
yeah nobody ever really gets hurt in it
yeah i mean they don't show anybody like
getting
murdered like they don't they do but i
mean they don't show
like for example the cut is so tight you
can't
it's amazing it's amazing and like you
guys there's a really old uh documentary
i think it's from 2000
and it's on 2b and um it's about the
texas chainsaw massacre it's basically
it's not so much a documentary
documentary it's basically just
interviews with
uh gunner hanson you know who has since
passed away obviously sadly
um and some of the other actors in the
movie and um
the guy that plays the hitchhiker who is
still alive uh edwin neal his name is
he said that he has won a lot of bar
bets over the years
with people who have maybe seen the
texas chainsaw massacre but they saw it
a long time ago
and they will bet large sums of money
that for example they saw that meat hook
going into that girl's back
or they saw franklin the kid in the
wheelchair
getting cut in half with a chainsaw nope
you didn't see that it's all suggested
it's all implied and the sound design
and everything like that
and it's just watching it again because
i watched it again yesterday like in
preparation
and it's just amazing to me how
the way you cut something and the way
that you use like sound effects and [ __ ]
like that
really makes you because i mean that
woman getting hung on the meat hook
is like super nasty even though you
don't really see anything
yeah just because of her reaction and
like kind of the sound that it makes and
like you just thinking about it
yeah it's just like it's [ __ ] crazy
first time i saw this
first time i saw this movie i was in i
was in michigan in
in high school and i was dating this
girl named cheryl
and it you know how it was back when
you're high school back then you know
what i mean you
read some [ __ ] from from the video store
maybe you know you
go on a date this is before you can
really afford to date
you know because you're in high school
you rent the [ __ ] v
rent the video she rented it she invited
me over to her house
we saw that [ __ ] in her basement den and
i don't even think i
even saw the movie made out through the
whole [ __ ] goddamn thing
made out through through the whole
goddamn thing
it's that that's very funny to me making
out through the chase
because pretty much the whole sound
design of this movie and i love horror
movies
the whole sound design of this movie
like once the [ __ ] really starts rolling
like about the 40 minute mark
it's pretty much just all chainsaw
buzzing and screaming
yeah i think that was the cut i think
that was the cover she
she was using to to convince her mom
that nothing was going on downstairs
i think that's what it was about because
all they could hear from downstairs
well i think i think i think it was like
well you know and nothing romantic gonna
happen we're gonna put some damn
chainsaw baskets
no man we did everything we could do we
still keep our damn clothes on
[ __ ] right those are the days man
yeah we're trying to keep our clothes on
well the funny thing too okay so the
texas chainsaw massacre
like i said great [ __ ] title great
[ __ ] poster
now one thing that they did that was
actually kind of
clever and actually got it um you know a
lot more attention than it may i mean
the title obviously got a lot of
attention but they did the whole thing
that it was based on a true story and
even at the beginning like they have
that opening crawl
they were talking about you know what
you're going to see is like real blah
blah blah that was john larroquette by
the way who was on
night court later on he got paid uh for
from what i heard for this for doing the
voiceover narration he got paid
one joint damn
just did it a lot of people didn't get
paid on this movie i'll get into that a
little bit
but um yeah so so it's kind of like
made to be like a true story
it's sort of inspired by a true story
i guess like it's kind of inspired by ed
gein just like uh
psycho is just like silence of the lambs
um
but the [ __ ] that happens in the texas
chainsaw massacre
like despite what the opening narration
would have you believe
that that exact [ __ ] did not actually
happen it is kind of based on ed geen
and the fact that i remember the time
when i went first women's skin and stuff
i remember the time we i first saw you
know i was with
with cheryl we were thinking she had
seen it already
yeah i was thinking i was getting ready
to see something kind of like faces of
death
oh right yeah this is back when faces of
death had a certain amount of
credibility
in the high school i remember those days
we actually thought
that oh like man man some of the [ __ ] in
there was real but it was real most of
it wasn't
most of it was fake or just you know
[ __ ] that they got off [ __ ] news
reels and stuff
yeah and really by today's standards not
graphic
yeah but frick freaked us out back then
this one man i i think that i think the
suspense was kind of like yeah this is
going to be some bad [ __ ]
but i never got to see it you know i'm
talking about that first time dude
like i said but you foremost took over
hormones took over
and i'd look up every now and then and i
was like
but you know what i mean i saw it again
later and was able to watch it
it did kind of have that [ __ ]
nasty illicit feel to it the faces of
death kind of had
yeah like it was an underground movie
enough film like a snuff film i mean the
cinematography is nice
you look at it now though you look at it
now you know [ __ ] you know
and now that i'm in my wiser years i
understand
what they did yeah and they shot it it
was
pretty uh pretty brilliant by today's
standards but back in those days
this is considered a garbage movie
though not respected well you know what
though
it's it was kind of messed up in the
mainstream well it was kind of mixed
because when it did come out
like you know you did have you know some
of the critics that were just like oh
it's you know just
it's trash but a surprising amount of
critics
including roger ebert understood what
they saw actually like
thought it was like a pretty damn good
movie and actually like in france and in
europe and stuff like that even though
they had some bands and stuff it was
like played at all kind of like film
festivals and
[ __ ] like that so i think it did you
know it got mixed reviews and some
people thought it was just like a
throwaway slasher movie but i think
largely people did
realize um what toby hooper was trying
to do with it because it did kind of
have
a deeper message to it i guess because
the thing about it is that
and like i said it's brilliantly shot i
mean it's the
the art design like the cinematography
is just really really nice
it's just when you watch the [ __ ] it
makes you it just
envelops you in this world it's like
this horrible
hot texas nasty it's like you can almost
smell it this is almost like the
world's first scratch and sniff movie
you know what i mean because you can
almost smell the rot
and the stink and the blood of like the
cattles and all the cattle
slaughterhouse and all that kind of [ __ ]
it almost smells like that yeah the
characters are are kind of believable
yeah they they have that 70s late 70s
vibe to them they kind of seem like
they're real people
and even the bad guys kind of seem like
they're real people
they're [ __ ] freaky pretty freaky
yes and and watching it again it's like
i feel like and you know there have been
like a lot of um you know obviously
there was texas chainsaw massacre too
uh which with dennis hopper and uh you
know chop top and all of that which was
actually
more like a straight up super gory
horror comedy fun fact the first i've
never seen it
oh it's good you would probably love it
yeah um the first time i saw that was
actually at a [ __ ] uh slumber party
yeah so that's what a lot of bunch of
little girls get up to
chainsaw massacre i really kind of to me
i think it's kind of comparable to
another movie that i like
even though i think i kind of like that
the other one a little bit better the
hills have eyes
well the hills have eyes was actually
inspired by this well craven was
inspired by this movie actually like a
lot of people
in fact rob zombie's whole entire
movie-making career is inspired by the
texas channels on massacre he has spent
his until
his whole entire life trying to
recapture
the magic that original masker
that original hills have eyes i love
that movie first time i saw it i was
like wow that was pretty awesome
good idea cannibals living up in the
[ __ ] hills inbred cannibal mutants
they were just they were just inbred mu
cannibals
i think they were mutants were they no
not really because they kind of looked
like later on in the second one they
said they were radiation mutants
yeah but no they were just inbreds and
remember they had the cute girl was
trying to get away from the family
yeah they had one of them that was cute
she was trying to get away
that was a good idea because not
everybody in a family you know
is going to be bad some people aren't
going to be step putting up with it yeah
but enough for it
i mean the thing about texas chainsaw
massacre like i said not only was wes
craven inspired to make
hills have eyes but also john carpenter
cited it as a big influence on halloween
like in the
sense that even though the two movies
are not that similar but in the sense of
like
a slasher movie about a villain that you
know uses a power tool and [ __ ] like
that because that was kind of like a new
thing
also another thing that i find
interesting about it too is that leather
face at least in the first movie
is i don't want to say he's sympathetic
but he is kind of sympathetic
only because the way gunner hanson plays
him and if you watch
interviews with gunnar hansen where he's
talking about like how he got into the
role
was that he basically thought of
leatherface as someone who was like
mentally challenged and he actually went
to like a special school and was like
watched the students like walk around
and like you know how they talked and
stuff like that so
he wanted to like you know put that
across
so he's leatherface is sympathetic in
the sense that
i don't think he really knows what he's
doing is
bad because i think that they the family
that he's grown up in
they've basically i mean their whole
lives revolved around the slaughterhouse
um the implication being that they've
been put out of work
um since you know they don't need
somebody with the sledgehammer to like
kill the cows anymore now they have like
a little gun and it goes much faster
so it's like all these people have been
put out of work and um
so but they've just been raised around
you know just
killing cattle and hogs and stuff like
that with sledgehammers and so you're
imagining that leatherface has probably
just grown up in this environment
he's mentally challenged he can't really
talk and it's like
that's all he knows how to do like you
know what i mean yeah there's another
one
there's another movie that was kind of a
rip off of this because you reminded me
of it that's also pretty good called
motel hell
yeah that's i like that one too this
might have
been that same it's in that same genre
was this like the first
hillbilly horror i don't know
started do i can't really because there
might have been some before this
deliverance might have
was deliverance out before this oh [ __ ]
that was it might have been a little
bitty horror movie
deliverance might have been eight 72
something [ __ ] now i don't even know
like offhand but yeah deliverance is
another good one not
quite horror more like action adventure
thriller thriller type with some horror
with some horror elements in there
that's where squeal like a pig comes
from oh
in case you didn't oh [ __ ] what's his
name baby youngsters out there yeah
ned baby yeah baby yeah that's where
that's where he
ned betty found out that if you're kind
of a chubby a chubby low tea male
another man might find you sexually
attractive
that's important or and he might be
inbred he goes hey you got a pretty
mouth
boy you got a pretty mouth remember that
yeah it's just like a creep
look like a little pig don't he i can't
i kind of feel bad for ned beatty
because i feel like for his entire life
people
but yeah so uh so let's actually go back
to talking about texas chains on
masquerade
so like i said this came out in 1974 the
idea for
the the rough idea was from uh ed gain
you know the wearing the skin and like
making [ __ ] out of bones and all that
kind of crap
but the whole chainsaw thing which i
this i find very funny
the whole uh you know thing of the
chainsaw being used as a weapon
toby hooper came up with that when he
was at a department store i think it was
sears like during the christmas season
one year like in 1972 or whatever it was
and it was getting he was like in the
hardware section like happened to be
like in the
chainsaw aisle and everything started
getting like really crowded like
everyone was like
packing around and stuff and he just
he's like and i suddenly just thought to
myself
man i know a really quick way to like
cut through this crowd i could just pull
one of these chains up and just
just go like that so that kind of gave
him the idea for doing it
now interestingly when they
so him and uh this guy named kim henkel
co-wrote the script they came up with it
and then they were looking for
uh financial backing now as it turned
out
what they ended up doing they got like
all the actors and [ __ ] to do it and
these were like all local like from
austin texas because that's obviously
where this was shot
and you know some were like comedians
and students and [ __ ] like that
so they put them all in the movie
they're basically like well we can't
really pay you
until we get a distributor now after the
movie was done
um it cost somewhere between 60 000 and
140 thousand dollars to make it because
i think initially the budget was 60 000
and they went a little bit over
um so after they were done it took like
a really long time to find a distributor
like almost a year and like all the
actors and [ __ ] that we're in we're like
is this movie ever going to come out or
you know what's going on with that you
know are we ever going to get paid
and what ended up happening was that the
uh the distribution company
that finally agreed to do it was like
connected to the mob and
so they ended up only paying like after
all their fees and [ __ ] like they only
ended up paying like eight thousand
dollars like the producers that would be
like divided among everybody like the
crew and the actors and everything
and it wasn't until new line pictures
bought the rights like in the 80s that
anybody actually saw any [ __ ] money
from this thing
even though in its first theatrical run
it was a massive success
it ended up making 30 million dollars in
1974
which is like 151 million in today's
money
yeah which on a movie that only costs
140 grand to make
i mean that's pretty [ __ ] good a lot
of that has to do with the title
well yeah i mean you have a title it's a
genius [ __ ] title if you have a title
that
that sensational back in the 70s you'd
sell a bunch of [ __ ] movies
well yeah especially if you were able to
get into theaters back then
you know which they evidently they did
and you would think not a living dead
would have [ __ ] raked in a [ __ ]
[ __ ] ton of movie
but they would the paperwork was so
[ __ ] up on the night
dead you can't made it out they didn't
end up making money yeah and like i said
they didn't end up making
much money off of this one either until
much later like when another
distribution because the mob took most
of it
um for the distribution but um millions
and millions and millions of people
like did see this movie and one it
helped that
you know everyone thought it was a true
story because like i said there was no
internet back then you couldn't really
check
yeah um so they you know the way that
they market it as a true story
uh the title of it and the fact that a
lot of
uh countries were coming out like you
know calling for it to be banned
and [ __ ] like that that just helps yeah
so that just like helped it strikes and
become like this really big like
phenomenon which it actually was
yeah back in the 70s you'd have all
little kids uh [ __ ] kids like my [ __ ]
babysitter kimmy back then smoking dope
going
we got to see that movie well yeah you
got to see that one like i said
yeah especially in california oh we got
to see that one that one's true story
they don't want us to know about that
one
they don't want us to die yeah yeah
that's
if you guys don't know my back back back
in these days my babysitter she looked
my name is kimmy she looked just like
princess leia
princess i had i even proved it to jenny
i showed a [ __ ] picture
yeah look at princess leia and that and
she would have [ __ ] loved this movie
her and her friends
well yeah this is yeah that's the kind
of [ __ ] that kids liked back then and
you know she was like 14 15.
they would [ __ ] love that [ __ ] and
you know what's really ironic about this
movie too
is that because of all the you know
calls to be banned and all this other
kind of [ __ ]
was that the reason why uh toby hooper
why
why there are so many um you know the
murders aren't explicitly shown
is because toby hooper wanted to get a
pg rating
because he did i did yeah he's like well
because it will you know the widest
possible audience you could get like
teenagers to see it and [ __ ] like that
yeah so they
submitted it and at first they wanted to
give it an x rating
yeah even though like i said it didn't
show anything okay so
really the only everything is
implication they just kind of like show
everything the only really gross [ __ ]
other than like the set design of the
bones and like the situation
i guess is gross dead pigs and [ __ ] or
whatever yeah yeah yeah
animals yeah yeah and they actually did
use real dead animals um you know they
they didn't kill any animals obviously
but they went and no they got them off
the side of the road
oh okay there's roadkill some of them
yeah some of them are broken and i think
one of the
one of the guys on the crew knew
somebody that was a taxidermy guy
and he borrowed some [ __ ] from it or was
a veterinarian too
and so they borrowed some [ __ ] from him
but also
um yeah so so everything is implication
i think the only
gross [ __ ] in it is the scene at the end
when um the hitchhiker gets run over by
the truck
and even that like you know they show it
but it's not like there's not blood
flying everywhere anything like that
and the scene where at the very end
where leatherface like where the truck
driver like throws a wrench at his head
and he falls over and the um
chainsaw goes into his leg well they do
actually show that
yeah funny thing about that scene was
that okay so
this this movie has like i said it's
such a it's so grubby and it's like
very documentary like even though it's
really nice looking and like i said it's
really like
you can just feel the stink and like the
heat and everything
the reason why i think it has that is
that a lot of the [ __ ] was real like a
lot of the all the dead animals were
real
um the heat was real for sure and i'll
get into that when i talk about the
dinner scene
at the end where everybody's just losing
their [ __ ] that was a real chainsaw with
real
thing on it like they just had to be
careful not to hit each other
with it like the hammer they use at the
end on sally that's a real hammer
um so [ __ ] like that and uh so the funny
thing was i was watching this interview
with gunnar hansen where he was talking
about that scene where this chainsaw
was just a real chainsaw and fell on his
leg and like you know cut it open like
that
he's like so what they did was they put
the jeans on and then they put like
uh you know they packed in like some
kind of guts because they used used
real guts mostly like real guts some
fake blood
and then they put like a metal cuff yeah
like over it that worked
um so he's like what ended up happening
so he's like so i
dropped the [ __ ] [ __ ] on my leg and
he's like it it went to the metal cup
and the slid how much
no it went to the metal cuff and then it
heated the metal cuff up
so much oh man that he thought and then
he saw the blood spurting and he didn't
know if it was
real bloody fake like because it felt
like it had really gone into his leg
because of the heat
yeah um and he's like so i didn't know
like i thought my leg had been cut open
yeah this movie was responsible for a
lot of stuff that happened in video game
culture too
the whole idea that a chainsaw is a
weapon kind of came from this movie well
yeah because this is
i think is the first one yeah the first
time i ever saw
a chainsaw in a video game was a [ __ ]
video game we had in the early 80s
called splatterhouse
where you played a jason-like character
with a [ __ ] hockey mask
you could pick up shotguns and chainsaws
and [ __ ] like that i think i remember
that game
yeah and then you're going through a
haunted house and trying to survive
there was a game based on this movie too
yeah interestingly then
then you started seeing it in doom of
video games it's called doom where you
could get a damn chainsaw
that was like one of the evil dead uh
you know the evil dead movies like they
used the chainsaw thing too where he
like
from what i remember though you know
what i mean when doom first came out and
splatterhouse and everything
the implication was that or what it was
culturally
hearkening back to was [ __ ] texas
chainsaw massacre
yeah that's what it was i mean this is a
huge hugely influential horror movie i
mean i i feel like if this hadn't been
made
like a whole [ __ ] genre of
other horror movies might not exist you
know what i mean just because this was
so influential
so yeah um one thing i wanted to talk
about too so
like i said i think everybody knows like
the [ __ ] plot of the texas chainsaw
massacre at this point he's like there's
five young people
they're actually going back to their uh
the sister and brother like sally and
franklin hardesty
um she's the blond girl he's the um the
paraplegic guy
their um relatives live in this remote
town or they used to
and uh at the very beginning you find
that someone's been robbing graves much
like ed gaine did and like making all
these constructions out of which like i
said that's
a [ __ ] the opening sequence of this
is great with like the patch
with like the [ __ ] corpses and [ __ ]
like that it's [ __ ] great and then
they pull back and they're like
there's two corpses like i was like
weird gravestone monument type of
type of thing like baking in the texas
sun and so
they have heard about this all this
grave robbing and they're going to this
town
with their friends like to see if their
grandpa's grave has been dug up so they
actually do have a reason to be going
there and they do
find out that their grandpa's grave
wasn't one of the ones but then they
said oh well
let's go look at my you know our
grandparents old house which is
abandoned now but there's like a
swimming hole and we can do all this
kind of other kind of [ __ ]
so i was watching uh dr wolfila who is
also a very funny channel he does like
horror reviews he dresses up like a
little werewolf that's very funny
and um so he was talking about this
movie and he called like all the people
in the
van like the scooby-doo gang which it
kind of is when you think about it yeah
this you feel like somebody got your
friend you got your shaggy you got your
velma got your daphne county i've been
where the idea came from
it might have been like going there in
the van yeah now i like the way that
they have the four characters like the
two couples who are like
you know quasi-normal like hippie-ish
kind of people like you would see in the
70s
and then they have franklin who
is a huge pain in the ass not only
because he's in a wheelchair but also
because he's like a whiny [ __ ] all the
time
so it's like i like that they started
out the movie with that conflict
like franklin has been brought along
because his sister was going along and
like everyone
no one's like overtly mean to him but
you can tell that everyone's just kind
of like oh here we go like you know
you know everything's a pain in the ass
because he's constantly whining and also
like because of his wheelchair he's you
know everything's more difficult
so there's some conflict even before the
you know they meet the cannibals or
anything so then
it's so you have that going and then
they pick up
a hitchhiker because 70s and that's just
what you did
and then this hitchhiker is super creepy
and weird
and uh talks about head cheese and talks
about how i used to work at the
slaughterhouse and how
it used to be so much better like when
they killed the cows with the
sledgehammer instead of the air gun
and all this other kind of [ __ ] he just
gets weirder and weirder starts taking
pictures of them like cuts his own
hand open cuts franklin's arms open
finally so they kick him out
and one thing that dr wolfilow pointed
out that i didn't realize
was that as they after they kicked the
hitchhiker out and they're driving away
and he like goes like that on the side
of the van with
the blood i guess he was like marking
the van so that when they stopped at
like the gas station
which is you know where the cook works
who was also a member of the family
which they didn't know at the time
then he'll know hey we might want to
kill and eat these people
because they were [ __ ] or whatever
but yeah so
because everyone's kind of working
together so they end up go they go to
the
abandoned house two of them go off and
uh they're looking for gasoline because
you know they stop at the gas station
there's no gas there and so they
see this other house with a generator
they figure they can ask them for gas
but it turns out it's the leatherface
residence or the sawyer
residence because that's the last name
of the family which i don't think you
find out until the second part actually
but i have to say that um
one of my favorite scenes in this is the
scene
the first time you see leatherface i
love
that there is like no build up there's a
this movie doesn't have a score
per se um really the score of it
is just like industrial noises kind of
like
or slaughterhouse type noises it's like
pigs squealing you know metal
scraping against metal [ __ ] like that
and it really kind of like
lends to the whole atmosphere of it yeah
it makes sense that you say that because
this
later on there's a band called skinny
puppy jenny jenny and i know they use a
lot of
little cuts and clips and
and audio samples from this movie and in
the sequel
and skinny puppy music is kind of like
that yeah a bunch of samples of
squealing
things and machines so maybe
it could be the skinny puppy got some
got some of their ideas from
the soundtracks of this movie i imagine
they probably did because like i said
the only music
that you hear in this is like you know
when they're in the van and like the
music is on the radio
that's like the only music you hear in
there you guys remember every time it's
just scraping
if you guys have never heard of skinny
puppy go go just go on youtube and look
at some of skinny puppies early music
like something off a damn mind to the
perpetual intercourse that's a good
that's a good album
yeah yeah what was the other one with
the [ __ ] uh
uh god's gift maggot what was that uh
what was the name of that
that album i can't remember yeah okay
but yeah so this will manipulate maybe
yeah
something like that but the first the
first time you see leatherface i really
really like it's
it's super quiet kirk um is going into
this house
like he hears somebody in there but he's
like you know and he needed some
gasoline so he was like
opens the screen door and he's like
calling out for somebody
and then he hears like this noise in the
background so he thinks there's somebody
back there
and he goes back and there's this really
great i love that they didn't do a
close-up
i love that they didn't like lead up to
it there's no like musical sting or
anything it's just like he walks to the
back
leather face pops out bashes him in the
head
with a [ __ ] hammer and he falls on
the ground and he starts [ __ ]
twitching
and then like leatherface drives me and
just closes the door and it's like from
like the end of the hall
i really really like that introduction i
just think that's really really cool the
way they did that
instead of like going like hey it's
leather face you know what i mean like
it's this new
villain it's just kind of like because i
like i said i feel like the sawyer
family
their whole thing even though they're
all crazy and they're all cannibals
and uh and [ __ ] like that but i feel
like
other than the hitchhiker who does seem
to enjoy
inflicting pain just because i feel like
the rest of the family
they're just kind of like well we just
got to kill people and they're
like not i think even the cook even says
at some point he's like
you know it's sometimes you just have to
do things doesn't mean you have to like
it
so i feel like it's almost like a
practical concern it's like well we just
need meat so
whack you know they're not torturing
them they're not doing anything like
that
really sally is the only one that gets
[ __ ] tortured
sort of like at the end yeah and uh
yeah so that scene in particular the
dinner scene
is probably what makes this movie
infamous
because you know once all of because
really the most of the scooby-doo gang
at the beginning i mean they get
dispatched
pretty quickly um and sally is kind of
the last one standing
and so she gets tied up they decide
they're gonna play with their food for a
little while i guess before they kill
her
so they tie her to a chair and there's
this really like horrifying
scene like where she's just tied to this
chair and screaming and there's like
meat on the table and they're all like
taunting her and [ __ ]
and then they want grandpa like to come
down who looks like a [ __ ] withered
corpse and they want her to
they want him to [ __ ] kill her even
though he's barely alive
yeah i remember that that was the scene
that was one of the scenes that really
stood out
yeah that's some creepy [ __ ] the old man
trying to get they're holding the girl
down and trying to get the old man and
he keeps like
too weak and like i said that's a that
was a real hammer so they had to like
be really careful like not to actually
like bash your brain
because it was like pretty good yeah so
this scene i was watching like all these
interviews with the
with um you know the actors and stuff
the scene i think
at the dinner table is probably only
five to seven minutes long
it took them 26 hours to shoot it
um and they had to do it kind of all at
once
just because they didn't have a lot of
money on this movie um
very famously everyone's costumes and uh
you know masked like latex applications
and [ __ ] like that
they couldn't wash them uh because
they were afraid that the laundromat
would lose them or that it would change
color and the
continuity would be [ __ ] up or
something like that and uh grandpa
they only had i think three appliances
for him
ironically the guy that played grandpa
was like one of the youngest dudes on
the case well that was a really really
young dude
um that appliance was made i believe by
like a plastic surgeon i can't remember
the guy's name but he made like the old
man appliance so he only had
like he only had one of those or two a
couple of those
so when they did that scene they had to
shoot it all in one go
so he wouldn't have to put all of it
back on again because they didn't have
an anymore spare so they're
in this [ __ ] farmhouse in texas
in august um
this farmhouse had no air conditioning
and no
ventilation and he had all those dead
animals in there and there was all these
dead animals and because they didn't
want the light
like [ __ ] up they had all the windows
like blacked out
because it was daylight but it was
supposed to be nighttime so they and
they didn't want to have to like you
know change for the lighting if when the
lighting changed outside because it took
so long to shoot it
so it's like so everything and they had
all the dead animals like the bones and
everything like that so that all stunk
if you watch like the dinner scene they
have like meat on the plates
and they said we couldn't um we couldn't
move that because
uh of the continuity again like so that
was
decomposing there was flies and [ __ ]
everyone's clothes
they'd been wearing for like a month
without washing them
in the austin of the summer so everybody
smelled
horrible and there's just no air there's
nothing
they said when you're when we're
shooting that scene it took 26
they're like every time they yelled cut
like a whole bunch of them would have to
run to one window and barf
like out the window because the smell
and [ __ ] like that was so bad and it was
so hot
so they said when you see that dinner
scene
everyone is like legit deranged
because this was like near the end of
the shoot it's like everyone was just
kind of over it and was just like
not even in their right minds anymore
what's funny about this movie and the
reason why would and you know
nine tenths of this movie is is
basically
historical context it's funny you know
what i mean if again
you if you were to make a movie of like
this today it probably just wouldn't
even be noticed
but because this is like one of the
first movies of its type and
and the time in which it came out it was
one of the first ones and it's just you
know people are still talking about it
today
yeah it's just it's it's it's well made
it's just it's just weird how
being a first makes a [ __ ] huge
difference well yeah
and um you know you can't really do it
you can't recreate it
yeah because like i said look look at
how much impact this had
yeah and think of how people perceived
this movie as being super violent super
gory
yeah and it's not really i mean it's all
like i said it's all in your imagination
but i think that's what makes it
brilliant because they didn't need to
show like and i'm not like
[ __ ] on movies that are really gory
because i like you know gore gags as
much as the next person
but the fact that he could craft a movie
like this
that just made you feel [ __ ] dirty
and
just is really like uncomfortable to
watch and just like this
nasty grimy like [ __ ] horrifying
movie
but he didn't have to show much of
anything it was all like your own mind
like doing the [ __ ]
job on you i just find it amazing that
you could do this again and it wouldn't
be noticed
well they did actually they're okay so
there was a second there was a sequel
um which is like i said was more of a
horror comedy because it kind of went
more in that
direction which okay fine the second one
is actually really good
it is super super over the top gory but
it's also hilarious
um other than that i haven't really seen
any of the other because i think there
was a sequel called
leatherface that was kind of or a
prequel i don't even know which one it
was
now there was a remake well those are
licensed remakes and stuff i'm talking
about
you could have a person not having had
that has nothing to do with texas
chainsaw massacre or anything you could
just make a movie kind of like this
using this technology and and this and
and and no backing and no real money you
could make it and it wouldn't be noticed
well yeah because well there's the
market
some there's so much of it yeah and the
reason that it wouldn't be noticed
nowadays because
because of this movie yeah so because
somebody already did it it's just
being first is very [ __ ] important
and just about in everything
but it's just amazing to me like nightly
living dead like not a living dead great
movie
yeah it was the first one like it it
didn't make any money because they
didn't [ __ ] fill out the paperwork
right
so it's just it's public domain okay but
you can go out and make another movie
just like not a living dead it would
never be a classic
well yeah because that already happened
yeah that already happened and it
happened back then
so much of it like you said it's
cultural concept it's cultural context
that has
it's nine tenths of it and um
if you want to make a classic movie to
be remembered
for all times today it's got to be
totally original you got to do something
wildly different wildly different and uh
man it's hard to do because everyone's
trying to do that yeah because it's like
you know you can't really make another
zombie movie you can't maybe you can
slash your movie you can't i mean you
can but you'd have to go
really out there like what the [ __ ]
and you also have to not only would you
have to go way out there with the
concept but you also have to make it
enjoyable enough and not off-putting
enough
yeah that people aren't going to go a
lot of it has to do with what the
thresholds of the people are at
at the time you know when we when this
when we were watching this movie it was
[ __ ] far out
you know yeah because there was nothing
really like this not really
but now you know the the standards are
set so high
i mean the only thing that's going to be
really far out if you actually kill
somebody on screen that might be that'll
be far out
but you'll also go to [ __ ] prison but
yeah please don't do that yeah
and they got guys doing that they're
called serial killers so you can see
their [ __ ] you know what i mean like
that [ __ ] crazy dude that ate his
chinese boyfriend
the one that ran over to europe and got
caught what was that sucker's name
anyway he he made a film of himself
killing and eating that kid
and uh it's not it's not a good movie
well arm and myvis did that too
but it was a four hour video i don't
think he was trying to make a movie he
was just trying to document it
but uh you know yeah dumb crazy
well yeah that is dumb and i feel like
that's not even original because they've
been making snuff movies and like fake
snuff movies like since
the 60s or earlier yeah so so that's
what i mean so i feel like even if you
really did do it every nowadays it may
be like
like no one would care yeah like dude
you killed that dude that wasn't even
original that scene yeah
seen it yeah well that's what i mean
it's like people are like really ripping
off that other
guy you're ripping off a movie you know
i saw that movie the thing about it
though is that even
what because i watch like um you know a
lot of other horror critics that are my
age and i
i've watched some that are younger and i
do feel like texas chainsaw massacre the
original
does actually have a very large fan base
among younger people so i do think that
younger people
see the artistry behind it see
the um originality because i think
sometimes you have to like you said you
see it in the context of its time
yeah and it also kind of had something
to say about um
you know the way that you know with all
the [ __ ] about the slaughterhouse it's
like look at what's happening in the
slaughterhouse and like this family is
also doing this
um kind of talk about how how shitty
people are to each other
there's a lot of like the kind of
vietnam era stink about it which
you know a lot of [ __ ] happened and i
think that toby hooper said that
one of the things that he um wanted to
convey
with the based on a true story thing
which is like not just because it was
like
you know better for marketing because
everybody's like oh true story i want to
see that
but he's like also because of the whole
like uh thing where
you know now the government is lying to
you because of like watergate and
vietnam and everything like that
so he was kind of trying to make a
statement about that also
like so trying to he's like hey i'm just
kind of lying to you like making this
movie so
but so there's a lot more going on in
this [ __ ] movie it kind of has this
janky taste to it too it looks like it's
some kind of illicit crime scene photo
and the [ __ ] the acting is
good but in a bad way it's good
it's it it almost kind of like uh
mano's hands of fate at times but like a
higher
higher caliber version of that movie
it's a lot i mean it's a million times
better looking
yeah a lot better looking but there's
just something
awkward about the acting in it
you know what i mean it's almost kind of
like it's real it's just weird you know
i mean did she didn't
it is very documentary it's kind of
weird you know
the way the the tone of of the movie
but that's that's what's adding to it
it's
it feels very cheap but very
effective it's immersive like i said
it's almost like a sensory experience
yeah and it's uh
hills have eyes has moments of that in
it too
depends uh what scene you're talking
about but it's pretty good movie
it's a pretty good movie i mean the
thing is like you said some critics saw
for what it was they knew
what they did they knew what they were
doing they knew the tone that they
wanted
and there's so much of it like i said in
some so many of the shots
like the shot where they where they
first like before even anybody gets
killed
but when they go into like their
grandparents abandoned house and like
one of them looks up in the corner and
there's just like a nest of daddy long
legs up there like
yeah like just everything like that just
makes you feel
like you're just in this [ __ ]
environment
you know what i mean it's just it's very
it's very very immersive
and then like later on with all the
[ __ ] sound like all the screaming and
all the [ __ ] scraping
and just all it really like just puts
you in there well for me after you
you first started getting into that tone
when the crazy kid gets into the car
with the [ __ ] scooby
yeah and and the conversation that's
going on in there you know it's it's
real odd
and you know it's very odd yeah the tone
i love that guy
edwin neal they had like an extended
interview with him on this uh thing that
i saw on toby
and um he said he's always very uh
surprised
like when he went for other jobs
subsequently like he kind of got
typecast a little bit yeah um even
though he hadn't done any acting jobs
like that
before he was like he mostly did comedy
and [ __ ] like that
he said i walked into toby toby hooper's
office
and he's like and i just he just kind of
looked me up and down and he said
can you do weird and he so he said the
first thing that he thought of was that
he had a nephew
that had some um mental issues
and he said so i just started acting
like my nephew
and i got the job you know so that he
said that's exactly like what his nephew
acted like
like he was because he's almost um he's
crazy clearly and
homicidal clearly but he's also like
childlike in his enthusiasm which i
think like makes him even creepier
another thing too that um i love like
the character of
uh the cook who was played by jim cedaw
who has also passed
away um but i love him because for a
while you don't know
that he's like part of the sawyer family
because he just works at this we
slaughter barbecue or whatever
and so like sally runs there for help
and at first he's all helpful and
grandfatherly and stuff like that but
then you can see like little
like the craziness like starts to leak
out you know what i made
like the [ __ ] great shot where he
just puts her she thinks she's safe and
then he brings in this big [ __ ] sack
and then she's like what are you doing
and he's like but well you know you just
get just get in the bag everything's
gonna be okay all this other kind of
[ __ ] then he puts her in the bag and he
puts her in the truck
and he's driving and he's like no don't
cry don't do that and then he starts
poking her with a stick like hey
you know what i mean it's just like the
creepiest [ __ ] ever with his [ __ ]
teeth and everything
because he seems like so nice and normal
and then like all of a sudden he's like
like he's getting off on it and it's
just like super super creepy
oh i should say too that the house where
um where leatherface and the family
lived
uh that house is actually still standing
they've
moved it from where it was um and
like i don't know how far like not super
far but they moved it somewhere else and
they restored it and it's a restaurant
now which i think is very funny also the
gas station
the with we slaughter barbecue that has
also been renovated and they turn it
into a bed and breakfast
like a texas chainsaw massacre themed
bed and breakfast
um but the other house like the
abandoned house that they were in the
beginning that's uh not there anymore
because that was like shitty at the
beginning
but what i was gonna say was that uh so
they made did so they did a remake of
this
in 2003 i think it was 2003 2004
um i actually was like not any time i
hear that they're going to make a
remake of like a classic like this i'm
always kind of like oh boy
but i think i actually did go see this
in the theater
and it's pretty [ __ ] decent i have to
say i mean obviously i still prefer
the original but there are some other
horror uh reviewers i'm not going to
mention any names
but they actually prefer the remake to
the original
now the remake is pretty scary and it's
like way gorier
but i think they did a good job they
went back to because i feel like like i
said after two which i love
but that was kind of more horror comedy
so i feel like it it kind of almost went
like the nightmare on elm street
direction with the first ones like kind
of serious and scary and then they just
got funny
um so the remake didn't do that
you know what i mean they actually did
try to capture like the original
feel uh of you know the feel of the
original
and so i would actually recommend seeing
i'd be interested to see if uh
if anybody is prefers the uh remake to
the original but i
actually i really did enjoy the remake
which i didn't think i would i still
like the original better
um just because it has that gross
snuff film 70s kind of vibe that i don't
think can really be replicated
by something that was made in the more
modern era
but it was a very good effort and it was
like way way better
than i was expecting but yeah so texas
chainsaw massacre it's
everywhere it's on [ __ ] shutter it's
on it might be on tubey as well i'm not
really sure
no maybe it's not but i think i'm for
sure it's on uh for sure it's on chatter
and it's like if you haven't seen it
what the hell is wrong with you if
you're a horror fan
you really need to see it it's brilliant
and um
really one of the most influential
horror films in my top 10
easily um you know so you know check it
out or watch it again if you haven't
seen it for a really long time
we'll see you on the next one bye